toutes les nuits
je fais le même rêve
hélas
le cauchemar commence
j'ai fait ce que je devais faire
pour protéger notre monde vous ne pouvez
pas tout contrôler et strange
vous savez ouvert le portail qui relie
des super et nous ignorons quelles cette
roue quelque chose mon le franchir
que savez vous du multivers vision avait
une théorie
il pensait que c'était dangereux
il avait raison
est ce une noble estivale
la profanation de la réalité
restera pas impuni
[Musique]
nous devrions lui dire la vérité
chossat fiennes de t'échapper
[Musique]
freiner les règles
vous devenez un héros
quand je le fais je deviens l'ennemi
je trouve pas ça normal
[Musique]
stand